[MUSIC]
My name is Miki Malcolm
only from Venezuela.
And I'm the founder of Ribbit capital,
based in Silicon Valley, and
entrepreneur, who build their companies in
Latin America, in Europe and in the US.
And I want to start.
I'm very happy to make
this panel work today and
an honor with the people that are here.
I'll start and we can take it from here.
So let me start with
a very quick question.
What did you get when you put
two Colombians, two Venezuelans,
one Brazilian and
one Argentine in the room.
I think you get a better soccer team,
a better football team.
[LAUGH] Let's start with quick
introductions around the table.
All of you are run some of the most
successful and better known brands and
companies in Latin America.
All of you are from different
places in Latin America, but
all of you share one very important topic.
You all attend an MBA and you all
attended the MBA at Stanford at the GSB.
So, we have people that go,
Marcos is our older statement here.
He is yes, he is class of 99.
And I'm not going to keep going
because he will make anybody else.
But I'll go if you can quickly introduce
yourselves even even though you know
each other.
But for the rest of the we both
are attending the webinar.
Just quickly,
what year you attended Business School?
And what do you do today?
And then we can start with some questions
about about Stanford about the business
program and about Latin America.
Marcos you're the oldest statesman.
So we're going to start with you.
>> Hi everyone.
How are you?
I'm Marcos Galperin attended
GSB 97 through 99 and
I started MercadoLibre out of the GSB.
Actually drove my first investor to
the airport from a class at the GSB.
>> Laurie.
>> Hi everyone I'm Loriann Garcia
most people call me Laurie.
I went to the GSD from 2008 to 2010,
and I'm a co founder.
I'm one of callbacks co founder currently
I lead everything related to culture and
organization and we started Kulak about
six years after I graduated from the GSB.
>> Welcome Laurie, and Gabrielle David.
>> Hello, everybody.
I'm Gabrielle Braga from Brazil.
I went to the GSP from 2010
until 12 together with Davie and
a few other entrepreneurs in the region
I started at right off the school.
Actually we started discussing
the idea doing school and
came back to Brazil to study.
>> And hello everyone, David Valiz
also from 2010 to 2012 originally
from Columbia started new bank also
right after business school and
at 2012, beginning of 2013.
>> Hi everybody, from Beijing.
I went to GSB 2012, 2014.
I started doing getting into
real estate before GSB and
it was something I was very passionate
about and during GSB went deeper into it.
Right after GSB started doing traditional
real estate and started covering
with the idea of something or
doing something different around 2017.
That's what led to what I'm
currently doing at the house.
>> Well, welcome to all of you.
It's a privilege to have you here and
to dedicate this next 45
minutes to talk about an MBA.
Why matters.
So, let me just throw out this
first very simple question.
Of all the things you could have done,
when you look back in time,
why did you choose to do an MBA?
And if we can do a free flow I can ask
each one or you can just go and start and
just intervene.
Why do you choose to do this?
Who wants to start?
>> I can start.
>> There you go Laurie.
>> I remember a few years ago I
was looking into grad schools and
when I did my research I
realized that an MBA was
the most complete program
that I could find.
Most master's degree would probably you
focus on something professional and
learning a skill during
the MBA especially at the GSB,
you go through a personal transformation
and a professional transformation.
Because it's not just about going to
class it was about the people you meet
the classmates and all the new
things that I would be exposed to.
And I wanted to go to Stanford because,
I love what they were always said
about changing the world and
I wanted to be part of that
>> For
myself, I went to undergrad in
Brazil I always started in Brazil.
Had the chance to study some good
schools here but didn't have the kind
of world class exposure that no you
can have any school like Stanford.
And besides the academic and
the professional impact that could bring
my life I think would be in a different
person after spending two years
with people from all over
the world different culture,
different religions,
different backgrounds,
all kinds of different things that
can influence my personality.
My understanding about how things work,
globally, and
eventually even my kids can be friends
with the kids of my friends from
MBA that are from all over the world and
do a bunch of interesting things.
And I think specifically about Stanford
was a very small community that Ivica
would have a deeper
connection with those people.
And be exposed to the Silicon Valley
which was a big dream for
myself sometimes is excused for
your church to spend two years or
more in the middle in the heart
of no tech innovation in
the world
>> To me it was
a bit of a moment to take a step back.
I had already been in business
I was really investing for
a few years before business school.
I always wanted to be an entrepreneur but
I didn't really see a clear path.
Just simply leaving the job and
then figuring out how to start something.
So it was a bit of a breather to take
a step back and understand, okay,
what's the next 10,
20 years of my life going to look like?
And can I think opportunity of those years
to do some switches to get more people
to work in some skill sets in a way he was
almost everything beyond the business.
The business aspect was actually
the least interesting part to me.
It was more about the non business
classes as well as the community and
the people that I was expected to meet and
frankly, just the time in the network,
that's going to give me a little bit of
a breather to try to understand that so.
So from that perspective I
think worked out really well.
>> Who was a bigger partier or socializer
in Gabrielle and you in that class?
>> I think it was pretty
competitive I must say.
>> That it [INAUDIBLE] [CROSSTALK] [LAUGH]
>> You competed hard,
I don't know, I think we tied.
>> Marcos.
>> I think similar to what has been said,
I also wanted to take a breather.
I might add I was particularly attracted
at Stanford because of the golf course
which ended up being very important for
my career as well as John Donahoe
the CEO of VB, was an avid golfer.
So that was an added skill for
me, but joking aside no,
I wanted to spend some time in the valley,
I really wanted to be in the West Coast.
I had done my undergraduate
in the East Coast.
And I was convinced that the
entrepreneurship skills that I was going
to learn at Stanford were going to
be very useful for me and
it definitely turned out that way.
>> Hiro, anything to add?
>> Yeah, I think for me it was I
was clear what I didn't want to do.
I didn't want to do something
very specific, very technical.
I just had the gut feeling that there were
many things to learn about the world and
to try different things.
And I think, like Lauren said,
the MBA afforded that
spectrum of different things
you could expose yourself to.
>> There's a few questions coming
through the Q&A that I may throw and
just change a little bit
the ones I had in mind.
But one question that
comes here on the thread,
it's interesting because it's
something that I did not go to MBA.
I did not go to Stanford and yet I'm here
helping promote a program for
Latin Americans to come to.
We were going to talk more about it
later towards the end in the chat.
But one question that came around was,
do you think it was worth the investment?
You're making a big investment in
yourself, and you're deciding to use that
money, or your personal money and time to
make a two year investment in yourself.
How do you think about that versus
starting a company without it?
It's one of the questions that
came through to the chat.
Since all of you have started companies,
I think it's one of the best panels in
Latin America to ask this question.
>> Let me give that one a try first,
and I think it's a great question,
but because a lot has changed
definitely since I did my MBA.
But also I think since my colleagues
here as well because of the availability
of online education that has
boomed in the last few years.
I think that if you are really thinking
about the educational experience
mostly because of the skills
you want to learn.
The finance skills,
digital marketing skills or
whatever, I think you can get
those today online quite well.
I think that what Stanford provides is
a much more comprehensive experience I
think.
In my case I literally drove to the
airport, the person that invested in my
company, my classmate, Stelio Turda
has been working with me for 23 years.
He's the president of the commerce
part of our business,
the president of the payment
side of our business.
The guy was doing the MBA one
year ahead of me, so basically,
I built the company with my classmates.
And that is something that you will
never get doing an educational
experience online.
So I think it depends very much on what
you're looking to get from your MBA.
Stanford is really,
really unique in many aspects.
>> Yeah,
I would very much agree with Mark on that.
I think one thing that somebody once
mentioned to me is that if you take
the long view on your career and
you think you're going to be working what?
I don't know, we're going to be
working 50, 60, 70 years, who knows.
Investing two of those, 60, 70 years into
a fundamental difference experience,
where you're going to be exposed to
different ideas, different people.
And open to have that network
take you in different unexpected
directions is a very
interesting opportunity.
I, similar to Mark, was I ended up working
in GSB with Sequoia for a year and
suddenly, they became my
seed investor in Newbank.
If I hadn't gone to Stanford I don't think
I probably would have ever met them,
I don't know if I would have ever been
able to raise the capital that I needed
for what I wanted to do.
And so, similarly, as I said initially,
I think you wouldn't do business
school necessarily for the business.
If you want to do business,
you want to do accounting, read a book,
you want the marketing read a marketing,
take a course.
But it's all about everything else that's
not the business is entirely ecosystem and
when you get exposed to that makes it
a very powerful two year investment,
either from a time or
even from a money perspective.
>> I identify with a with a quote I heard
Joel Peterson say at the last
launch I had at the GSB.
Somebody asked him that
similar question he said,
look the bottom 10% of people
don't deserve to be here.
The top 10% of people
don't need to be here, for
the other 80%,
it's a transformative experience.
I consider myself to be part of that 80%,
well, I did at the time,
I polished my financial skills,
I polished my marketing skills.
But it was a much more comprehensive
experience learning more
about the world and
learning more about yourself.
And building relationships that really
unleashed a lot of personal value.
>> And to add,
I think of course you can do something,
have a great business
without going through an MBA.
But I think that if you go through
an MBA especially through Stanford,
it kind of gives you a superpower,
a super booster accelerator.
I see right now, my day-to-day work,
most of the things that my tool
kit that I use came from Stanford.
Everything I learned in communications,
knowing how to write this,
how to say that, how do you actually
get people to engage with your message.
Everything I learned in
leadership skills and
how you actually build relationships
within your team to be able to achieve
something that goes beyond
what you could do by yourself.
All of that I remember,
sitting in Stanford,
reading the books,
practicing role playing, and
all the things are the things that I
use right now daily, most of the time.
>> And Lory for you, Carlos your
cofounder of Kodak and your brother,
he went to Oxford for his MBA and
you went to Stanford.
Is there any competition
at home around this topic?
>> Nope, [LAUGH] you think
there would be but there isn't,
we compete about a lot of other things,
but not about that.
>> So
let me switch a little bit the question,
you all run now big companies,
you're all recruiting a lot of people.
When you are in that
process now as a founder,
as the leaders of your
companies in your recruiting,
what are you seeing in Latin America?
What are you seeing from people that
are coming from either location?
What are you needing the most?
What would you like to see more of?
In the same way Marcos was mentioning
that part of his team that runs
are all Stanford ex
alumni's that they did.
And I think Gabriel can also
talk a little bit about that.
>> Which I think I just jumped in,
I forgot him.
But how do you think about
the potential of people coming
out with these programs in
your company's futures?
Maybe we start with you, Gabe,
since I forgot to ask you and
you can answer-
>> [INAUDIBLE] I only agreed with
everybody, so
it would be kind of repetitive.
So in our case, almost entire,
his active team, we're part of Stanford,
many of those who were in the same class.
I think that today, what we see is this,
the people that have the chance
to go through this programs,
they have a much accelerated
learning curve about everything.
They put much more faster way to access
the answers or what they need to learn.
Sometimes they know already,
because they were exposed by that.
But if they don't know, as Laura was
saying, they can quickly tap their network
or expand their horizons there and
learn quickly about those things.
And I would add to that, in our time,
we are particularly restricted
from people that actually had experienced
doing what we are trying to do.
In our case,
it was very hard in the beginning,
if you're the first cohort
of startups in Brazil.
And today, I see a big difference
of companies that are starting, and
can actually recruit people that spent a
few years, working in other companies and
can come, and they hit the ground running
because they already were exposed to that.
So if you have a chance to
go to a program like this,
spend the time work in Silicon Valley or
other companies.
It's something that it's super
valuable for you coming back and
wanting to join a company
in Brazil that or in Latin.
That usually can't have access
to talent that actually was
exposed to doing things like
companies in the US have, right?
You hire an Engineer there,
they spent a few years on one, two,
three companies that
you're aspiring to be.
Here, that's much harder and
easier to find with people
that are in these networks.
>> And Marco,
since you've been at GSB the longest,
if you had to do the MBA again,
what would you do differently this time?
>> Well, that's a good question.
I think when I did my my MBA,
I focus most of my efforts in attending
lectures by guest speakers and
building relationships with
my classmates, and both on and
outside of the golf course.
And I think that's what I would do again.
I think that was the most valuable
things for me were those,
just getting inspired by the amazing
lecture speakers that we would have.
Again, one of those ended
up investing in my company.
And the incredible classmates I had who
basically helped me build my business.
But are also many others that are not
working, my colleague, lifelong friends
that are two different things and
are just an amazing community to be with.
So I think that's one of the most
valuable things that GSB provides.
I didn't get into more
technical classes at the time.
I think I would these days,
I would do some programming.
I would learn some more code,
something I didn't do then.
I would definitely, rather than
learning the basic accounting skills or
maybe basic statistics skills, I would
definitely learn basic coding skills.
>> David?
>> Not much to add to be honest, I think,
I was happy to be able to
have spent a lot of time
with friends and
meeting really good people.
Expanding the horizon with
the job opportunities,
having been able to work through my
second year, get me up to speed.
I had the opportunity to start spending
time in looking at investing in
Latin America.
And to me, that was what I wanted to do.
I want to be sure I wanted
to go back to Latin America.
One of the advices that I
received from mentor was,
I think this is helpful perhaps for
everybody in the panels which
are on the community here.
Which is strategically,
you want to position
yourself where there is a scarcity and
know where there is oversupply.
Now I always thought that a Latin American
that went to US and stayed in the US
had no real differentiation,
was going where everybody was.
But a Latin American that could go to
the US and then go back to Latin America.
That's where there was real scarcity and
continues to be a scarcity.
And so I think that's ultimately very
related to the impact that you can
create in some of the countries
that we come from.
So to me, having been able to
have a foreign at Stanford but
spending a lot of time with the community
and investing in Latin America.
And looking at what was going on in
Brazil, in Colombia, and Argentina, and
other countries was a really great
opportunity, so I'm glad I did that.
>> You guys in combined,
you've led companies that in aggregate
are worth more than $100
billion in Latin America.
You all came to Stanford, you all started,
you all decided to go back to Lat Am and
started companies there.
When you think about going
back to Latin America and
taking from where David just left it,
what was the hardest part of
going back after Stanford?
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> Go Gab, right.
>> So I agree very much
with what David just said.
I had the opportunity to work
at Airbnb during the MBA, and
decide to come back to start
a company out of nowhere and
that had no reference outside of Brazil.
So I think the cool part was to go and
come back and be an actor of change and
try to change somethings
that really annoyed me.
The experience that we had in Brazil and
the opportunity to fix a problem here.
And that it was opportunity for
me and also a responsibility.
Because I felt empowered to take
everything that I had learned there,
the network that I had.
Then come back and
kind of bring to Brazil and to Latin,
something that could
impact many lives here,
most probably much more different than I
would have done if I stayed in the US.
The hard part was that everything
is harder in Latin, and
everything is lower in Latin.
So there, you talk to a bunch of
people and they want to invest.
Here, nobody wanted to invest in us and we
spent many, many years just bootstrapping
with, by the way, a few friends from
Stanford that were the first angels.
But it took a while for us to really have
a series a shitload of money coming in,
which is a very different reality today.
And also hard to find talent that just
as I talked to, we were doing that for
the first time,
we had no real idea of what we were doing.
And I would have paid
a lot more if I could find
talent that That would show me
a little bit of the way and
we had to learn almost
everything from scratch.
I think this is also changing but
it still is a big difference
from doing business in Brazil,
or lot on comparing to the US.
>> Anybody has a different, I want to
ask that question to each one of you.
It's an important one.
What's the hardest part of going
back to that diamond working versus
staying in the US for you?
>> I was going to say like,
I think that the personality
of Latin Americans is amazing.
It's warm, it's foreign.
It's outgoing, so building personal
relationships in Latin America is great.
But the way we organize ourselves
as societies is still far from
being perfect and that's a challenge for
everybody's daily life when you compare
it to the US or you compare it to Europe.
And that imposes challenges on
on how you raise your family
differently on how you live daily
security issues in the region.
Or social issues in the region so
in to some extent it's
a trade off on the quality of life and
the quality of life you can lead.
That's also very challenging that's
also what makes doing something for
the region like inspiring and want to
make once makes you want to do more but
it's but it's a challenge,
it's a personal challenge.
>> Yeah, I would add, for
me there is no playbook,
when you look at the US what was going on
in Silicon valley for entrepreneurship.
There was some guidelines that
would tell you want to raise money.
It's going to hear you want to
include talent in your team,
you kind of do these things.
Here at least five years ago there was
nothing you had to kind of make up
everything along the way.
And I would also add that when you want to
solve one problem in Latin America and
you start solving it, you need to
solve like a hundred surrounding it.
Like if you want to say I want to
start a company to sell phones and
then you realize okay, but
there's no connection to the wire and
then I need to add
the connection to the wire.
Okay, but now there's no this, no post and
you have to have everything around
to make your business work.
That if you probably would have, if I
would have seen that USA would have said,
okay, I'm only going to focus on this and
then everything around kind of works.
And it's going to kind of
help me to the environment.
Here you have to assume
nothing around works and
you're going to have to solve it to.
So you're going to have to build a lot
of expertise around your main core
business,
>> I would say,
sorry, we're saying something Mickey.
>> Go ahead, Marcos.
>> Sorry
>> So,
I will say what first of all I think
Latin America is changing a lot.
And very fast I think it's important for
everyone to have that in mind because
many of the things that were very hard.
For example like getting funding or
finding good technical talent,
although things have improved a lot,
and very, very fast,
obviously, they're still a war on talent,
etc.
But the same thing happens,
everywhere in the world today.
So many things have changed for
the better.
Having said that, I would say,
the unpredictability of
Latin America is just incredible.
It's incredible and the longer you operate
in the region and in the more countries
that you operate, the more impressed you
are by how unpredictable things are.
And that obviously is fun, that is very
fun on the one hand but it's very hard.
It makes it very hard because,
it's unpredictable in many different ways.
And, it can be very hard to build
businesses for the long term.
It's sometimes it's politics, sometimes
it's unions, sometimes its judges.
Regulatory frameworks you end
up encountering things that you
would never dream of
encountering in the US.
Maybe once every 20 years,
in Latin America you encounter
five of those per year.
So that in my opinion Is probably one
of the hardest things to build and
grow a business for
the long term in the region.
And I don't see unfortunately,
I don't see that changing for
the better I see changing for the worse.
For example,
one of our most predictable perhaps
our only predictable market was Chile.
And all of a sudden Chile now has become,
nobody knows where Chile
is going not know.
So it's a it's interesting that's
something that you will not
definitely not find in the US or in Europe
>> I'm going to I like
this topic of Latin America I want to stay
here but I just have to make a very small
there was a question by Fransisco somebody
named Francisco was actually quite funny.
He said, all of you guys sound like
you have a very different accent
of English and
different level of knowledge of English.
How difficult was to do your TOEFL and
your GMAT?
And if you remember your score,
does anybody remember the score?
>> What's the GMAT?
>> [LAUGH]
But-
>> As expected it was hard It was really
hard but I hit harder than the GMAT
was the first three months at school,
trying to really be able to talk and
understand that you read half the speed.
And when you write your write
like a quarter of the speed.
It takes a lot of pushing and willpower
and headaches to be able to try to stay
at the level in which you can
actually contribute to the class.
I don't know, the rest of you agree
>> And it's not only the classes,
because the classes are more formal,
more organized, so, if you're used to
reading and writing, and maybe not so
used to talking, but you can get going.
The social life is also very draining,
you go to a bar in It's loud and
everybody's talking over each other and
make jokes that you don't understand.
So it's kind of you think that
you go out and you relax but
you come back like exhausted nd then
you have to keep talking about it.
But get used to it so it's part of
life and after the pains one of
the benefits as well
>> There's a lot
of questions going back to
the Radam that we have.
It's hard to get all of you to be on one
chat, so let's take advantage of that.
Record amounts of money being raised
there has never been a better time
to be an entrepreneur in Latin America and
to start something is this hype?
Is this real?
Is this like anything that
it will go through different
cycles where what is your mindset to this?
Because there's a lot of questions
on the chat coming in from a lot of
people actually trying to understand
how important is to fundraise or
if fundraising to measure success?
How to think about starting
a company today in Latin America
with all these founder
abilities to have money versus
stay in some other place so
just a little bit.
Love to get your thoughts on those topics.
>> Nikki you should answer that one.
You're investing in the region
>> Fair.
>> So, I too was an entrepreneur in
the region as most of you know, and
I am shocked with the amount of
capital that is available to start.
I wish that had been the case 20 years
ago or even 10 years ago or even.
I had a chance to meet David when he
was raising a seed round and I passed.
He was a Colombian going to Brazil, but
we corrected the mistake later in life and
we invested later.
But I will say what is
different is it's just
the quality of the mission of the people.
I find that for the first time ever,
I'm seeing people who truly want to change
the region and have the tools and the
technologies there these days to do it.
So I find that to be different
than anytime before,
in terms of what can be done.
But I do think that the record amount
of money is not a recipe for success.
If anything,
I'm more concerned that it will create
the wrong incentives and
greed will overtake the mission.
That's what I worry the most right now.
>> I would just add to that in your ECC.
You see, you probably have the best
perspective from all of us given your
investing activity.
But whenever you actually see the big
numbers, even if the money has increased
a lot in South America, it's still very
much below what you would see in other
geographies, even compared to Asia,
or to India, or to US.
So availability of capital is
really everywhere and yes,
it's great that it has improved in
Latin America but it's still relatively
small compared to the size of
the opportunity that exists in the region.
And I think it's at a point right
now where people are still very much
grabbing the capital and
being responsible with it.
You generally do see businesses
that have good business model,
real unit economics, real business
fundamentals since the very beginning.
You still haven't really seen a lot
of the craziness that you sometimes,
I think, you see in the US and Europe.
I would say still, it's becoming more
appropriate, but it hasn't gotten to
the point where it's absurd or people
are wasting money all over the place.
That leaves as my two
cents on that perspective.
>> I would add that it was hard for
me in the beginning to envision
that we would build companies.
They scaled up through, you're seeing
some of the companies here and
the speeds that we're
seeing this companies grow.
And is very good to see some
examples that that's possible and
you see as robust companies with strong
talent platforms, strong cultures,
and they really know how to develop
products that will solve big problems.
And then I think what these sayings
is just a follow up to that.
But the challenge for
myself that sometimes we struggle here is,
as Marcus was saying,
it's very unpredictable in Latin.
And so on the one hand, it's very
good to put money in the bank, and
then comparing to a few years ago where
you didn't have the money in the bank and
you had to keep going.
So it's much better to have
the money in the bank, but
you don't know if this wave
is going to continue or
just be a short wave of
capital that comes and goes.
And then this push and break,
it's kind of hard in the companies.
And if we could have
more predictability and
more stability of this capital and
you could plan around it.
It would be much healthier for the
companies, I think to agree that I need
to raise now, then raise a bunch of
cattle may be more than you need,
they got the evaluation
the higher than it should.
And you spend that in a way that
maybe a year or two from now,
you want to sustain the same rhythm, and
then you have to pull back in the company.
So that's kind of one of
the hardest things in Latin,
I've seen the last two years.
For example, every quarter or
every semester,
we had to adjust our plan due to external
factors in a way that was like, man.
[LAUGH] I know that's the dynamic business
and we are just seeing all the time.
But in Latin, it's kind of a bit more
exciting and I think funding coming and
going is one of the biggest reasons for
that.
>> Sometimes I think the hype
if where there is hyper-reality,
I think sometimes, you don't know,
until things unravel.
But I'm not thinking about the future but
about the past.
I compare the headlines of today and
they may seem somewhat exuberant
to the headlines of approximately 12,
15 years ago.
And the kinds of companies that were
raising money were companies that were
doing oil exploration in
the Columbian Amazonian basin, or
in the in Brazil, and
that was the exuberance then.
And I'd rather much have the kind
of money that is flowing today into
the region flow into the kind of
businesses that it's flowing into.
And that there be a bubble there,
bubbles always tend to correct.
Then in the kind of sectors that
we were seeing it flowing into,
not about a decade ago, so I'd rather
much have this kind of market dynamics.
This kind of destination for
money than the ones that
the region saw in previous cycles.
>> And I would add that beyond the money,
I'm very, very excited of what I'm seeing,
because I'm seeing a lot of talent.
There are a lot of people now
that see entrepreneurship,
that really want to take on a problem and
solve it and they're seeing,
with a capital flow that it's
something that can be done.
So I think it's just going to be a lot
more stories of entrepreneurship from
Latin America,
people doing amazing things.
Because I'm seeing that people that want
to become entrepreneurs, that want to join
an entrepreneurial team, which is amazing,
and we didn't have that five years ago.
>> Loreanne, there's a question that came
up a couple of times around you're
the only woman in this panel.
How do you see that Latin American
startup environment evolving for
more gender equality?
>> Usually, I'm the only woman in the
panel, unless it's an only women panel,
which there are not a lot.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Well, there's still a lot to do.
There are a lot of social things going on
in Latin America that's been going on for
a while, in terms of what's
the women's role and how we could do.
So we're not there yet, we still need
to figure out a way to get more women
interested in becoming entrepreneurs.
Get more women interested not only
in becoming entrepreneurs but
in solving bigger problems.
Because as women need,
we usually tend to go to smaller markets,
we need to go to bigger markets.
And also to trust ourselves more
that we that we're going to do it.
So it's going to take a little bit, but
I know we're a few women
here as entrepreneurs and
we're really trying to see how we
can have a multiplying effect.
>> That means you have Christina
as a co-founder in new bank,
as you think about, as in you see
a lot of people that are starting
companies in Brazil,
are you seeing any other changes there?
>> Yeah, I think I've seen changes.
I don't think it's as fast as we all wish.
I think Chris, my co-founder,
is still one of the few
Brazilian co-founder,
one of the large tech companies, and
that's very surprising in a country
where over 50% population are women.
But I see it more and more,
it's happening more and more.
There is not only More women going
in starting their own businesses,
but also venture capital focused on
supporting women led businesses.
And I think just the entire ecosystem is
arranging itself to make it much more
inclusive and available.
So I think it's too early.
It's definitely not where it should be but
it's the trend is good.
>> One question that comes a lot here
is how are you recruiting people for
your companies?
What language is the official
language companies are speaking when
you hire technologists and
developers in different regions.
As Latin America becomes as all of you
are growing to multiple countries,
how is that an issue and
opportunity in the future?
So let me put this way.
Marcus, what's your official language in
Mercado Libre, in the technology team.
>> Meaning coding language or
>> No
>> They speaking language,
when you have people
from different countries.
>> It's Spanish,
typically Spanish historically,
would I speak to Stereo we'll
communicate in English?
And the official language or
the presentation Every material that is
written in the company
is written in English.
So our board operates in English,
we present to our investors in English so
we present to ourselves even though
we might be speaking in Spanish,
the written material,
everything is in English.
And, Brazil is 60% of our revenues.
But most of the people speak
Spanish in the company, but
it's kind of out of respect to
the Brazilians we use a neutral language
which is English oftentimes when we are
communicating with our Brazilian teams.
>> Havid.
>> We started with English first,
we had a team where one of
my co founders is American,
dear co founder is Brazilian,
I'm Colombian.
So English ended up being the default in
our team of the first ten ,15 employees
that were already a number of people from
the US who didn't speak any Spanish and
Portuguese.
So English became the kind of
the Lingua Franca of the entire company.
That has been an opportunity as well as
a challenge I think opportunity is that as
we go now globally expand
where we're recruiting
talent we already have people
from 45 different nationalities.
We're very spread around that is already
a culture that everything is in English.
Although communication is in English,
people can get up to speak quickly and
what's going on, and it's easier for
people from around the world to to
get integrated with different teams.
The challenge to that note is that
especially in the earliest stages in some
of the countries,
a lot of people don't speak English.
You might become a very
exclusionary company,
if you require English as a requirement
to enter you might be leaving a lot of
really important talent that just doesn't
speak English didn't have the opportunity.
So, the challenge is how do
you provide English lessons?
How do you have inclusive HR process of
recruiting processes to allow to recruit
people, sometimes from lower income
segments that don't speak English?
Train them in English and make them
able to really fit within the company.
That's one of the biggest challenge
that we're working right now
because I don't think the answer also
is we're an English company, and
all Latin Americans need to
figure out how to speak English.
At the end of the day we
are a Latin American company by itself.
So the challenge is finding that mix and
ultimately is about the Spanish people
have to spot learn Portuguese and English.
The Portuguese people have to
speak Spanish and English and
try to get everybody to speak
all the languages ultimately
working some kind of mixture that so
far is working.
>> Gabriel N Kinto and Err.
>> Yeah, I think it's about the same
thing we're still not operating in
other countries.
But, since the beginning we also have
an internal documentation English.
And sometimes we have the opportunity
to bring people from from outside
even before the remote world phenomenal.
And I think that's an opportunity,
it's the challenge for
everybody to adapt to that.
But as David and other said here,
I think is also the opportunity
to force us to do that.
So if you have a chance of working
a company that will allow you and
force you, and
require you to develop English.
It's just better than going to school and
not practicing it outside.
So I think it's a forcing mechanism and
is inevitable.
So, nothing very different to add
there
>> Well it feels
that we have the common learning here
is English is an important language for
presentations and for recruiting,
challenging, getting out more and
more people as companies grow to speak
the language or to get the bases running.
But it is something that I will tell you
was not the case 15 20 years ago, so
it's changing in the region and
it's changing really fast.
We're going to transition, there's one
question that I'm going to answer but as
we transition to having the Stanford team
give a little bit of some data on GSB.
There's a question here that says I feel
Venezuela is a different case from most of
the region given its
current economic condition.
What would you recommend to an aspiring
MBA student who would like to eventually
come back to his country and
make a difference?
So I'm going to take a stab at answering
that question guys feel free to jump in if
you want to.
But to that question, this is part of
the reason why I started sisapuelle
which you're going to
hear in a couple minutes.
A little bit more about
from this team at Stanford.
We're basically creating this program
that allows any Latin American to apply.
Any Latin American that has
certain financial conditions
below a certain salary range to apply for
free to Stanford Business School.
And once you get admitted and
you get accepted,
there's a program where we will
sponsor have a fellowship and
have a few students per year that
will get scholarships to attend and
get most of his tuition paid for
by Sisapuelle.
With the purpose that if you go back to
the region after studying and you end up
having an impact and in you're not going
back to the country that you are from,
we will waive any other
that you have remaining.
So the idea is to get more people
to attend school in the US get
prepared with the way Marcos,
Laurie, Dahveed, Dave,
Halomeen had a chance to be exposed,
go back to the region have an impact and
do it in a way that is cost efficient for
you.
And that's part of what we
want to do as Sisapuele.
And in Venezuela in particular.
I hear you I'm from Venezuela.
It's hard to go back now.
But you can definitely go
back to the region and
we'll cross our fingers that when
it gets better, then we can enter.
This generation of people that went to
this business schools that build these
networks of relationships, will have
the impact to change an entire country.
The same way all of you are changing
your country's by bringing better
financial services, better e-commerce,
better ways to buy or
finance a car, better ways to buy or
finance your home or
finance or finance a rental these
are all things that impact society.
And funny enough we got an amazing group
that went to the school and had and
had a chance to do this.
So with that I want to
transition quickly to
the Stanford team to see if they
have anything they want to add.
>> Thank you, Mickey, and thank you so
much to Mickey and our panelists.
This was just fantastic and the time
flew by, I feel like I could listen to
your insights for a long time,
so much appreciated.
And Mickey thank you so much for teeing
up the information about Si se puede.
As Mickey mentioned, and
thanks to his generous support we are so
excited to offer this program at the GSB
specifically to those who are from
Latin America who meet, as Mickey
mentioned, a certain financial condition
that's making less than US $40,000
when you apply to the GSB.
If you meet these conditions,
your application fee will be waived.
So this is not something
you need to apply for,
there's no additional paperwork needed.
This will just happen in your application
if you meet these conditions.
We're so excited to be offering this.
So for those of you who are on today,
thank you for joining us so
you can learn about this.
And for
those who are just hearing about it,
feel free to share this
with your friends too.
I did see a question in the chat.
Just, is this the same as Knight Hennessy.
And that's a great question.
As Mickey mentioned, not only are we
trying to make it possible for
you to apply with this
application fee waiver,
but we want to enable you to be able
to attend also, should you get in.
So Mickey mentioned the fellowship
money that is available,
once you are admitted,
our financial aid is need based.
So should you have a high level of need
there are fellowships available to
help you be able to attend.
And one of the questions that was out
there is this the same as Knight Hennessy?
I want to point out that there
are fellowships specifically to support
students from Latin America,
but there are also many other fellowship
programs such as Knight Hennessy.
That's another way for
you to apply to that program separately.
You would have the potential to be
a knight Hennessy fellow as well
as a Stanford GSB student.
So Si se puede and
Knight Hennessy are separate programs.
But they are indicative of the level
of support that's out there for
you to be able to attend the GSB.
There are millions of dollars
of fellowships awarded,
our average fellowship each year per
student is around 40,000 that's average,
meaning many students get more than that.
And so whatever year you
are thinking about applying,
I encourage you to seek out what
financial programs are available.
But right now, Si se puede is available as
an application fee waiver and fellowships
should you be able to attend, in
addition to many other programs we have.
So I did see a few other questions in
the chat that were admissions focused.
So I encourage you all to check our events
page if you are interested in attending
an information session that's more
about the application process.
And we'd love to have you there and help
you learn more about applying to the GSB.
I know we're a few minutes over, so
again, I just want to wrap up in
thanking Mickey you're so much for
not only his support of this program but
for helping bring this
dynamic panel together.
It was such a great event.
So great to hear all of your insights.
I thank you all for your time.
And again,
thank you to everyone who attended today.
It was great to have you with us and
I hope you found this as
inspirational as I did.
>> One last question to
finish to the panelists.
Who was the best student?
>> [LAUGH]
>> I was not in that top 10%,
I can tell you that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Neither was I.
[LAUGH]
>> So
I'll finish it up by saying to all of you,
thank you.
I know you're super busy.
I appreciate you taking
an hour of your day for this.
Appreciate all of you.
Thank you, Lisa from Stanford for
putting this together.
And we look forward to seeing a lot of
admissions, a lot of applications, and
hopefully a lot of fellowships from Si se
puede for more Latin Americans to come
to Stanford and then go back and
have an impact in South America.
[MUSIC]